et avec nous pour en parler ce soir jean
didier berthault porte parole de xavier
bertrand dont 15 je le disais qu'il nous
a rejoints sur ce plateau candidat à la
primaire pour la présidentielle 2022 je
parle évidemment de xavier bertrand pas
de vous
bonsoir et merci d'être là ils font face
aux membres d'europe écologie les verts
vous êtes vous en direct par skype avec
nous ce soir merci à vous d'être larmes
au tout d'abord sur notre
reportage un gringo le père de famille
nous dit mon rêve c'est de travailler il
avait dans un futur clairement avec ses
enfants
et à la place il vit vous l'avez vu dans
une caravane à 8 et il dit surtout un
enfer bureaucratique qu'on a du mal
c'est vrai à comprendre qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire
yves contassot
écoutez moi ce que je vois c'est que je
prends la situation parisienne par
exemple ça fait des mois et des mois que
les personnes essayent en vain d'avoir
un rendez vous avec la préfecture de
police pour que leur dossier soit
simplement examiné c'est un traitement
que je n'ai jamais vu jamais vu ça fait
plus de vingt ans que je m'occupe de de
ces questions d'immigration de
régularisation je n'ai jamais vu une
telle inhumanité les gens sont dehors on
les envoie vers des d'espèces de camions
qui sont là des camionnettes où on leur
dit vais essayer sur internet alors que
sur internet y absolument aucune
connexion possible on les renvoie de
semaine en semaine et à personne pour
simplement examiner leurs dossiers or
s'il ya des gens qui de toute évidence
ne seront peut-être pas régularisée
d'autres ont parfaitement le droit
d'être régularisés et pour autant
personne personne n'est en capacité de
les accueillir on voit à quel point il
ya une volonté de presque de
stigmatisation de vexations de
traitement inhumain c'est vraiment
scandaleux et sa déshonore le pays qui
se targue d'être le pays des droits de
l'homme par jean didier berthault bon ce
cas est un cas un petit peu particulier
parce que ce père de famille est
apatride et des balkans mais enfin c'est
vrai qu'il est ni français ni rien du
tout et on le laisse un petit peu livré
à son sort est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce qui a été dit
il ya une forme de stigmatisation de ces
personnes qu'on laisse sans même traiter
leurs dossiers il ya visiblement
effectivement comme l'a dit yves
contassot une question et d'inhumanité
mais pourquoi avoir de l'humanité il
faut qu'il ya des règles et le problème
c'est que dans un pays où il n'y a plus
de règle dans un pays où on ne contrôle
plus on ne maîtrise plus les frontières
où on laisse les situation dégénérer
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui forcément
on arrive à des situations qui
deviennent critiques on l'a encore vu ce
soir avec un un bateau et trente et une
victimes dans la manche c'est
inacceptable c'est révoltant mais ceux
qui sont responsables de cela c'est ce
qu'ils ont laissé faire le fait que l'on
ne maîtrise plus nos frontières et tout
le problème est là c'est d'avoir aussi
la fermeté nécessaire pour que ces
frontières une fois maîtrisé on puisse
est effectivement traitées avec humanité
ceux qui ont le droit de rester sur le
sol français mais le problème il est là
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est aujourd'hui
plus en capacité de faire cette
distinction est que l'on se retrouve
face à cette situation dramatique et
face à des filières qui s'organise et
qui vivent sur la misère des gens ils
font assaut effectivement sur cette
capacité
ça revient souvent nous ne sommes plus
en capacité d'accueillir et de gérer
l'état se retrouve peut-être un puissant
tout simplement dépassée
écoutez il faut pas se raconter
d'histoires on est en campagne
électorale alors les républicains ont
choisi d'instrumentaliser la question de
l'immigration en courant après les voix
des de marine le pen et d'eric zemmour
mais la réalité est très différente
on peut prendre quelques exemples le
stade de france a été quasiment
exclusivement construit par des sans
papiers aujourd'hui tous les jours tous
les jours je croise des gens qui sont
sans papiers et qui sont employés par
des entreprises qui savent parfaitement
qu'ils sont sans papiers et pourquoi
parce que ça leur permet de ne pas payer
un certain nombre de taxes ne pas payer
des impôts de ne pas
garantir la sécurité des personnes et
donc tout ça est d'une hypocrisie
absolue et c'est connu évidemment des de
tous les responsables politiques donc on
n'est pas du tout dans une situation de
nos contrôles on est dans une situation
volontairement on ferme les yeux sur un
certain nombre de malversations de
réseau on l'a vu alors malheureusement à
ce qui s'est passé en biélorussie où y
compris des états instrumentalise la
question de l'immigration et l'europe
choisi faut le dire de délayer à
certains pays la question de
l'immigration que ce soit de manière un
peu officiel avec la turquie et en
payant très cher pour ça ou bien de
manière alors beaucoup moins officielle
est beaucoup moins humaine vis-à-vis de
l'italie où d'autres pays qui sont aux
premières loges de la question de
l'immigration et c'est pas en fermant
nos frontières qu'on réglera la question
on le voit bien il suffit d'aller à
calais c'est pas la frontière française
qui est fermé c'est la frontière
anglaise et donc c'est pas du tout comme
ça qu'on va régler la question j'ajoute
le dernier point c'est que on parle
toujours de l'immigration on oublie de
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui
vont travailler à l'étranger et que dit
on à ces français vous ne devriez pas
partir à l'étranger vous devriez rester
travailler en france là comme par hasard
on me dit rien on considère que cette
immigration là elle est acceptable mais
que dans l'autre sens ça ne l'est pas
jean didier berthault est la réponse à
yves contassot ya une forme de double
langage et notamment en période
électorale écoutez la période électorale
oui elle existe après ils feront face
aura quand même du mal à me faire croire
que lui aussi n'est pas en campagne
électorale pour pour ses propres idées
donc je peux pas laisser dire qu'il ya
une instrumentalisation sur un sujet
aussi grave le sujet il est de reprendre
la maîtrise de nos frontières et d'avoir
des d'avoir des mesures qui sont des
mesures concrètes quand en novembre
quand en novembre 2012 après le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy la
circulaire a permis des régularisations
et que nous avons aujourd'hui trente
mille régularisation qui sont à peu près
annuel cette circulaire il faut
aujourd'hui l'abroger il faut traiter du
cas par cas on voit bien aujourd'hui que
on n'a pas les moyens de mener la même
politique migratoire que celle qui a été
menée depuis des années donc soit on
prend des mesures soit on continue à
favoriser un terreau qui sera propice
aux extrêmes je crois que ce n'est ni la
volonté des républicains ni celle de
monsieur contassot donc c'est à nous
aussi de prendre nos responsabilités
mais il faut les prendre aussi de façon
lucide visiblement ce manque de lucidité
aujourd'hui d'une certaine partie de la
gauche nous le payons cher parce que ça
fait dix ans aujourd'hui que cette
dérive existe on va regarder une des
premières réactions télégramme celle de
laurent fortier on confond droit d'asile
pour les personnes réellement persécutés
et accueille des réfugiés économiques et
les ong alimente la confusion nous
n'avons pas les moyens d'accueillir les
migrants économiques seules les
personnes réellement persécutés devrait
être temporairement accueilli voilà ce
que nous dit laurent papa pas seulement
c'est à dire qu'il ya un moment donné
l'immigration elle vient dieu deux pas
de la part des familles da par des
étudiants de la part des gens qui
demandent un travail donc c'est au
niveau de ces trois flux là qu'il faut
agir avec ce que propose d'ailleurs
xavier bertrand c'est une solution de
quotas de façon à ce que ray on puisse
réguler nous mêmes aussi bien les
regroupements familiaux que les quotas
étudiants que les visas pour travailler
aujourd'hui c'est quarante mille
personnes qui demande à rentrer sur le
territoire pour travailler est ce que
aujourd'hui moi je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec les chiffres qu'adonis
contassot tout à l'heure sur la partie
de travailleurs de deux travailleurs
sans papiers oui il y à des sociétés il
y à des entreprises aujourd'hui qui
utilisent ces sans papiers ils doivent
être contrôlés il ya des contrôles
sociaux évidemment on doit lutter contre
ces filières clandestines mais tout à
l'heure on parlait de la frontière les
accords du touquet il faut aussi les
dénoncer c'est pas à la france de garder
la frontière du royaume uni surtout pas
dans les conditions actuelles et on voit
bien que c'est une aspiration
aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est absolument scandaleux et on est en
train de faire de la manche cimetière
marin comme on a fait de la méditerranée
un cimetière marin on peut pas laisser
faire ça et c'est aussi de notre
responsabilité on va prendre jean didier
berthault tous les problèmes là l'un
après l'autre yves contassot déjà sur le
droit d'asile comme nous le disait ce
téléspectateur confusion entre
droit d'asile réfugiés politiques
réfugiés économiques vous êtes d'accord
avec ça où tout le monde est à traiter
avec la la même égalité je rajoute donc
jean didier berthault et les
républicains qui propose une immigration
choisie ça fait d'ailleurs longtemps de
cette idée est un petit peu sur la table
écoutez c'est pas très sérieux parce que
y compris j'entends parler l'ensemble
quasiment des candidats a l'air de faire
un référendum d'abord il serait
probablement
un air très probablement non
constitutionnels anticonstitutionnelle
les meilleurs spécialistes glisse ça
n'est pas possible donc déjà une
question de sérieux dans la proche des
problèmes deuxième élément le
regroupement familial vous le savez il
ya des droits supranationaux qui ne
permettent pas de faire tout à fait ce
qui est proposé troisième élément les
étudiants diviser par deux le nombre
d'étudiants étrangers qui viennent mais
ça veut dire qu'on aura encore plus
d'immigration parce que ça veut dire que
si on n'est pas capable d'aider un
certain nombre d'étrangers à se former
et il retourne pour les l'immense
majorité dans leur pays pour aider
justement à ces pays à se construire pas
forcément avec nos règles notamment anti
environnementalement de quoi ils font un
travail et retourne c'est de
l'investissement
on sait très bien pour éviter une partie
de l'immigration économique il faut ces
pays la capacité de vivre par eux mêmes
et si on empêche la formation si on ne
veut pas les aider eh bien on aura
encore plus d'immigration économique
donc tout ça n'est pas très serré ubat
dernier point oui sur l'asile d'asile
c'est un droit indiscutable et personne
ne peut le remettre en cause là encore
sauf à sortir une fois de plus de ce
qu'est la france non je crois que à un
moment donné je comprends les arguments
on les connaît par coeur les arguments
d'une d'une certaine d'une certaine
gauche qui aujourd'hui privilégiée
la filière d'immigration avant même
avant même les français voilà je pense
qu'il faut qu'on
te laisser dire ça je suis désolé les
frontières les faits c'est ce que
propose xavier bertrand c'est la triple
frontière c'était les frontières déjà
qu'on puisse avoir les relations avec
les pays d'origine de l'immigration qui
ensuite les frontières au niveau de
l'europe puis ensuite la frontière la
frontière nationale sur sur les droits
d'asile il s'agit pas de refuser le
droit d'asile il s'agit de le réformer
pour qu' on puisse avoir déjà un dépôt
de droit d'asile immédiat qu'on ait une
semaine pour demander son droit d'asile
et non pas plusieurs semaines voire
plusieurs mois comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui quand on vient d'un pays et
qu'on est persécuté c'est tout de suite
qu'on demande de droit d'asile et
qu'ensuite la l'instruction soit fait
aussi rapidement qu'on puisse les
contrôler et qu'on puisse aussi avoir
des empreintes digitales pour savoir
aussi où vont ces gens comment comment
aujourd'hui il s'intègre aussi dans sur
notre territoire est ce qu'ils vont
apprendre le français enfin je veux dire
on a quand même le droit c'est quand
même pas un gros mot de dire que on a
aujourd'hui où on ne parlait tout à
l'heure pour le pool pour le logement et
pour un certain nombre de sujets le fait
de dire que les français aujourd'hui
souffrent il faut déjà trouver des
solutions pour les français que
l'immigration soit un complément un
certain nombre de problématiques
qu'elles soient nécessaires on l'a vu
notamment sur des étudiants et soit des
étudiants et sur des filières de haute
enfin on va dire d'une d'une
particularité très très importante qu'on
puisse le faire oui mais on peut plus
continuer à ouvrir les vannes comme c
est ensuite à gérer des problèmes ça
n'est plus possible je vois
nationalement déborder les quatre
on va vous laisser un monde meilleur
mais ça justement qui va dans le sens de
jean didier berthault nous avons du mal
à donner une vie décente à celles et
ceux qui que nous avons déjà accueilli
comment pourrais-je être encore d'accord
en faire venir d'autres alors que la
situation est catastrophique
c'est en substance ce que nous a dit
j'ai envie de vegas kenya cela descend
sur la préférence nationale monsieur
cantat somme la taxe sur la préférence
social qu est ce qu il yad un des sens
de dire compris quand on fait un coup
hier une préférence nationale et qu'on
défend son pays c'est quoi la descente
mais non mais je nomme je note jean
didier berthault que les propos de
marine le pen qui était stigmatisée par
les élèves y ont encore six à huit mois
sont maintenant repris par les ailes
ailleurs je le note c'est tout de la
note la préférence nationale qui est
illégal elle était dans le train du rtl
dans celui de marine répond monsieur
qu'on doit porter par les rebelles
évolution elle était dans celui du rpr
avant d'être dans celui de marine le pen
biens à vendre et ben c'est pas c'est
pas une fierté de notre part de dire ça
yves contassot justement cet argument il
revient quand même souvent dans la
bouche de certains français je vais pas
vous rappeler les sondages
vous additionnez les scores justement de
marine le pen et et d'eric zemmour par
exemple quand on cette musique qui dit
voilà on n'a pas déjà les moyens
d'accueillir correctement ceux qui sont
déjà là pourquoi on accueillir d'autres
qu'est ce que vous répondez vous chez
yannick jadot chez les verts mais c'est
simple c'est une question de choix c'est
une question de moyens effectivement
qu'on met ou pas au service des plus
faibles des plus démunis de ceux qui
sont dans la misère on l'a vu tout à
l'heure avec votre reportage c'est une
question évidemment d'investissements
quand on dit et qu'on voit que les plus
pauvres doivent encore s'appauvrir
tandis quelques riches s'enrichissent
encore plus on l'a vu au cours des deux
dernières années mes cd question de
choix politique c'est pas des questions
de moyens la france a largement les
moyens financiers économiques sociaux
efforts de régler la question de la
pauvreté régler la question n'est plus
démunis mais simplement il n'y a pas
cette volonté alors la droite le fait
depuis toujours en disant oui il faut
favoriser une certaine classe sociale
parce que c'est celle qui votent pour
nous mais bon on l'entend mais c'est un
choix politique ne disons pas qu'on ne
peut pas le faire jeanny d'hébertot et
ça sera le mot de la fin vous êtes
encore avec des vieilles références yves
contassot parce que ça fait bien
longtemps que les classes populaires
justement elles se sont rapprochées de
la droite parce que la gauche ne les
défends plus et justement on ne règle
qu'une règle plus les sujets pas ceci
parce que quand on quand on est
confronté le nombre réel problématique
bah vous le savez on est tous on a tous
été élu local moi quand je voyais le
sujet sur le logement tout à l'heure ça
me rappelle ce que je connais moi dans
mon arrondissement à un moment donné où
on voit un moment donné des situations
qui sont plus tolérables voilà donc on
peut plus faire face à ces situations là
et on y glisse sur dix
seulement si vous disiez que vous disiez
qu'on a les moyens si je vous disais on
a les moyens mais que vous disiez qu'on
a les moyens d'ouvrir les vannes et de
continuer à ouvrir les vannes comme on
l'a fait depuis des années on le voit
bien que ça n'est plus conseiller venir
son voisin qui a des fraudes qui sont de
plus en plus importante et
qu'aujourd'hui les français ne le tolère
plus donc soit on laisse les choses à la
dérive comme celle ci et on fera comme
je vous le disais tout à l'heure le lit
des extrêmes soit on prend les choses en
main on reprend le contrôle sur nos
frontières on reprend le contrôle sur un
certain nombre de décisions qu'on peut
prendre au sein de notre pays et on
arrivera à rétablir un ordre républicain
parce que je pense que notre idéal il
est tout cela c'est qu'un ordre
républicain soit rétablie avec avec ce
discours là nicolas sarkozy ne serait
pas français eric ciotti serait par
concept dont non ne seraient pas
français parce qu'ils aient
effectivement ils ont bénéficié du droit
à l'immigration alors et personnel je
vois que et versailles de l'enquêté
mais oui vous regretté que nicolas
sarkozy ait pu devenir français vers de
notre personne a défendu une immigration
zéro on a défendu une immigration
maîtrisée et une reprise en marbre non
non non vous utilisez les
instrumentaliser cette question qui est
d'ailleurs pas une des priorités dans
aucune enquête d'opinion cette question
arrive en tête très elles arriveront à
peu près en 10e position mais vous en
fait un enjeu majeur fait pas d'argent
c'est le sujet du débat donc on parle on
parle
des enjeux de la présidentielle il
compte à son nom mais pas du tout
un 1er mai elle apparaît dans tous les
sondages vous invite quand même voix la
soumission en 10e position oui tout
dépend désendetter d'opinion mais merci
en tout cas quasiment toutes ces études
d'opinion ça arrive très loin dans les
priorités merci cet essai les questions
environnementales
merci contassot merci jean didier
berthault d'avoir aidé ou en direct sur
hertz les français c'est la fin